let's say we have triangle ABC it looks
something like this a b c i want to
think about the minimum amount of
information i want to come up with a
couple of postulates that we can use to
determine whether another triangle is
similar to triangle ABC so we already
know that if if all three angles all
three of the corresponding angles are
congruent to the corresponding angles on
ABC then we know that we're dealing with
congruent triangles so for example if
this is 30 degrees this angle is 90
degrees and this angle right over here
60 degrees and we have another triangle
that looks like this that looks like
this it's clearly a smaller triangle but
its corresponding angles so this is 30
degrees this is 90 degrees and this is
60 degrees we know that X Y Z in this
case is going to be similar to ABC so we
would know we would know from this
because corresponding angles are
congruent we would know that triangle
ABC is similar to triangle X Y Z and you
got to get the order right to make sure
that you have the right corresponding
angles Y corresponds to the 90 degree
angle X corresponds to the 30 degree
angle a corresponds to the 30 degree
angle so a and X are the first two
things B and Y which are the 90 degrees
or the second two and then Z is the last
one so that's what we know already if
you have three angles but do you need
three angles if we only knew two aying
of the angles would that be enough well
sure because if you know two angles for
a triangle you know the third so for
example if I have another triangle if I
have a triangle that looks like this let
me look at draw it like this and if I
told you that only two of the
corresponding angles are congruent so
maybe maybe this angle right here is
congruent to this angle and that angle
right there is congruent to that angle
is that enough to say that these two
triangles are similar well sure because
in a triangle if you know two of the
angles then you know what the last angle
has to be if you know that this is 30
and you know that that is 90 then you
know that this angle has to be 60
degrees whatever you whatever these two
angles are
backed them from 180 and that's going to
be this angle so in in general in order
to show similarity you don't have to
show three angles or three corresponding
angles are congruent you really just
have to show two so this is will be our
the first of our similar similarity
postulates
we've called it angle angle if you could
show that two corresponding angles are
congruent then we're dealing with
similar triangles so for example just to
put some numbers here if you showed if
this was 30 degrees and we know that on
this triangle this is 90 degrees right
over here we know that this triangle
right over here is similar to that one
there and you can really just go to the
third angle pretty straight in it's
pretty straightforward way you say this
third angle is 60 degrees so all three
angles are the same that's one of our
constraints for similarity now the other
thing we know about similarity is that
the ratio between all of the sides are
going to be the same so for example if
we have another triangle right over here
let me draw another triangle I'll call
this triangle I'll call this triangle x
y and z and let's say that we know that
the ratio between a B and XY we know
that a B over X Y so the ratio between
this side and this side notice we're not
saying that they're congruent we're just
saying that their ratio we're looking at
the ratio now we're saying a B over X Y
let's say that that is equal to BC BC
over Y Z that is equal to BC over Y Z
and that is equal to AC that is equal to
AC over X Z that is equal to AC over X Z
so once again this is one of this is one
of the ways that we say hey this means
similarity so if you have all three
corresponding sides the ratio between
all three corresponding sides are the
same then we know we are dealing with
similar triangles so this is what we
call side-side-side similarity and you
don't want to get these confused with
side side side congruence
so these are all of our Simha
clarity postulates similarity postulates
or axioms or things that we're going to
sue and then we're going to build off of
them to solve problems and prove other
things side-side-side when we talk about
congruence means that the corresponding
sides are congruent side side side for
similarity we're saying that the ratio
between corresponding sides are going to
be the same so for example if this right
over here if this right over here is
let's say this right over here is 10 let
me have no one think of a bigger number
let's say this is 60 this right over
here is 30 and this right over here is
30 square roots of three and I just made
those numbers right because you we will
soon learn what typical ratios are of
the sides of 30-60-90 triangles and
let's say this one over here is 6 3 & 3
square roots of 3 notice a B over X Y a
B over X Y 30 square roots of 3 over 3
square roots of 3 this will be 10 this
will be 10 what is B C over X Y 30
divided by 3 is 10 and what is 60
divided by 6 well or say C over X Z a C
over X C well that's going to be 10 so
in general to go from the corresponding
side here to the corresponding side
there we always multiply by 10 on every
side so we're not saying they're
congruent or we're not saying the sides
are the same for this side side side for
similarity we're saying we're really
just scaling them up by the same amount
or another way to think about it the
ratio between corresponding sides are
the same now what about what about if we
had if we had let's start another
triangle right over here let me draw it
like this actually I want to leave this
here so we can have our list so let me
draw another triangle ABC let's draw
another triangle ABC so this is a B and
C and let's say that we know let's say
that we know that this side took it when
we go to another triangle when we go to
another triangle that we know that XY
that we know that XY is a B multiplied
by some constant
so eight so I can write it over here XY
is equal to some constant times a B
actually let me make XY bigger so it
actually it doesn't have to be that
constant could be less than one in which
case it would be a smaller value let me
just do it that way so let me just make
XY look a little bit bigger so let's say
that this is X and that is y so let's
say that we know that XY X Y over a B
over a B is equal to some constant or if
you multiplied both sides by a B you
would get XY is some scaled up version
of a B so you know maybe this is maybe a
B is 5 X Y is 10 then our constant would
be 2 we scaled it up by a factor of 2
and let's say we also know we also know
that angle ABC is congruent to angle X Y
Z I'll add another point over here so
let me draw another side right over here
so this is Z so let's say we also know
that angle a ABC is congruent to XYZ now
let's say we know that the ratio between
BC and Y Z is also this constant the
ratio between BC and Y Z is also equal
to the same constant so in the example
where this is 5 and 10 maybe this is 3
and 6 the constant we're kind of
doubling the length of the side so is
this triangle is triangle XYZ going to
be similar well if you think about it
there's only one if you say that this is
some multiple if X if X Y is this is the
same multiple of a B as Y Z is a
multiple of BC and this the angle in
between is congruent there's only one
triangle we can set up over here we're
only constrained to one triangle right
over here and that and so we're
completely constraining the length of
this side and the length of this side is
going to have to be that same scale as
that over there and so we call that side
angle side similarity side-angle-side
so once again we saw sss and SAS in our
congruence postulates but we're saying
something very different here we're
saying that in SAS if the ratio between
one course
and the other corresponding one course
in the ratio between corresponding sides
of the truth triangle are the same so a
B and XY of one corresponding side and
then another corresponding side so
that's that second side so that's
between BC and Y Z and the angle between
them are congruent then we're saying
it's similar for SAS for congruence we
said that the sides actually had to be
congruent here we're saying that the
ratio between the corresponding sides
just has to be the same so for example
SAS just to apply it if I have let me
just show some examples here so let's
say I have an angle here that is 3 to 4
and let's say we have another triangle
here we have another triangle here that
has length that has length 9 6 and we
also know that the angle in between are
congruent so that that angle is equal to
that angle
what SAS in the similarity world tells
you is that these triangles are
definitely going to be similar triangles
that we're actually constraining because
there's actually only one triangle we
can draw right over here it's a triangle
where all of the sides are going to have
to be scaled up by the same amount so
there's only one long side right here
that we could actually draw and that's
going to have to be scaled up by 3 as
well there's only half this is the only
possible triangle if you constrain this
side if you're saying look this is 3
times that side this is 3 times that
side and the angle between them is
congruent there's only one triangle we
could draw we could make and we know
there there is a similar triangle there
where everything is scaled up by a
factor of 3 so that one triangle we
could draw has to be that one similar
triangle so this is what we're talking
about SAS we're not saying that this
side is congruent to that side or that
side is congruent to that side we're
saying that they're scaled up by the
same factor if we had another triangle
if we had another triangle that looked
like this so maybe this is 9 this is 4
and the angle between them were
congruent you couldn't say that they're
similar because this side is scaled up
by a factor of 3
this side is only scaled up by a factor
of 2 so this one right over there you
could not say that it is necessary that
necessarily similar and likewise if you
had a trying
that had length nine here and length six
there but you did not know you did not
know that these two angles are the same
once again you're not constraining this
enough and you would not know that those
two triangles are necessarily similar
because you don't know those that middle
angle is the same now you might be
saying well there was a few other
postulates that we had we had we had a a
s when we dealt with congruence but if
you think about it we've already shown
that two angles by themselves are enough
to show similarity so why worry about an
angle and angle and a side or the ratio
between a side so why even worry about
that and we also had angle side angle
and congruence but once again we already
know that two angles are enough so we
don't need to throw in this extra side
so we don't even need this right over
here so these are going to be our
similarity postulates and I want to
remind you side side side this is
different than the side side side for
congruence we're talking about the ratio
between corresponding sides we're not
saying that they're actually congruent
and here side angle side it's it's
different than the side angle side for
congruence it's kind of related but
we're here we're talking about the ratio
between the sides not the actual
measures